so give it a little introduction about
myself and then open up with an overview
of what I want this session to go like
and then we can get into some stuff so
my name is hürrem I'm coming here from
Toronto actually so it's super warm here
I work for me to grieve it's and I work
on the individual life free insurance
side so you know how insurance companies
ensure you reinsures insure insurance
companies so it's insurance companies
all the way down so I primarily work on
a Python heavy team using machine
learning for underwriting analysis
mortality predict prediction and claims
management and if you're interested in
any of these or looking for a job we're
hiring interns data scientists senior
data scientists machine learning
engineers across the board and we have
an office in New York if you don't like
Canada so there's that and with that
we'll get into it so the motivation for
putting this talk together it's it's the
super novice talk and I'm gonna go
through very basic things that took me a
long time to understand when I started
working with docker so I found that
before I was that mean agree I used to
be at the University of Chicago Center
for data science and public policy where
I worked with like a very sophisticated
team building early intervention systems
for police departments such as we work
with the San Francisco Police Department
Charlotte Mecklenburg and there was the
first time that I saw docker being used
at like docker and pipelines running
Luigi and like really complicated fancy
stuff and when it came down to it my
interaction one that it was quite
surface like I build my model I'd put
put it somewhere and someone else would
like go in and work with it and that was
my first exposure and then I started me
an agreed and we have a pretty strong
date engineering team and most of our
devops stuff like you hear docker all
the time everywhere so in those
complicated use cases like doctor makes
so much sense but then I found that a
lot of issues I had things like even
working within our data science team for
example managing six different virtual
environments for six different prod
I'm on that could be easily resolved
using something like docker but I found
docker really hard to get into there's
like a lot of language around it there's
not a lot of there's a lot of really
good tutorials online but you like sit
down go through and like sometimes
there's information missing that you
fill in over time so what I wanted to do
was use this time to show you to walk
through some very simple docker
overviews present a potential use case
in a solution for a reproducible
environment and also one for running a
very simple model and you'll see the
model deployment thing it's just a
template and in that you can put your
own pickled model whatever mount as an
API put it on Azure AWS anything so just
the background we're gonna integrate
docker into some data science workflows
it's open source and the greatest thing
that it offers is it allows you to build
deploy and run your applications in this
container framework and the best thing
about that with everybody moving to a
cloud resource is that you can then
easily port your applications so that
they're live and if you do any of these
any of the following you have to share
even if you work in a research role you
someone has to be able to reproduce your
analyses and I've had many instances
where someone has a different version of
pandas and my metrics look different and
it doesn't make sense and it's like
because it's dependent on an umpire ea
ssin or something and then also run
large-scale data cleaning tasks where
you just want to spit up a container
read all the data in and write it all to
your database and not worry about
managing and you can have your own
workflows other otherwise and also
building dashboards and publishing
models so I did this project with the
Seattle Department of Transportation
where we took all of their data coming
in about bus stop usage and all the
shapefiles and everything they had and
then we built and like a shiny dashboard
on top of that and we wanted to be able
to serve it to them in a way that made
sense and they had a lot of issues with
like us hosting and on AWS and whatnot
so what we ended up doing was docker
izing everything and giving it to their
IT
apartment and then they could deploy it
in whatever environment they're working
in like I think they had like Microsoft
servers which I was like I don't even
know what that is like Linux or bust
right like so that was really easy for
us and that was the first time I saw
where a docker could really make that
transition really easy so I've got a
bunch of instructions up on this github
which if you can navigate to it I did
ask you if you install doctor and get
before but if you didn't that's fine I
just want to walk through so if you
clone the repo we can start yes oh it's
this one right here can you see it let
me put it on dry
you know I didn't think through this
kind of stuff is that better okay and
while you guys are going there what's
like the makeup of the room how many
people are students active data
scientists engineers cool all right it's
everyone there okay so the first thing I
want to start with is this docker start
notebook or folder and then we'll go to
the titled
docker client org so if you were able to
install docker before just run docker
run hello world that's like the basic
instruction they give you in the
installation - oh oh sorry dad take it
away - quick I'm going too fast too slow
let me know
so I will be doing it with you as we go
along and if anything breaks on my end
we'll figure it out it's a live demo
we'll see what happens everybody kind of
caught up yes
No okay well I'm just gonna get started
and we'll see what happens okay so I
have docker installed on my machine I
will just go type in this command oh
look unable to find image it's gonna
pull and then it gets give us a lot of
verbose instructions so this is a very
basic command the docker lets you figure
out what's going on and this is kind of
telling you that your installation is
working correctly so how many people are
actually going to be following along
okay Oh awesome
and does this work for everybody
everyone's at the stage okay so the
first thing we're going to do is we're
gonna run our first container so this
will be the primer or the background for
when we start talking about all the
terminologies like images containers
clients demons and whatever that is
so we'll start and so in your terminal
you just type docker pull Ubuntu this is
where it's gonna go and it's going to
download this image so essentially
what's happening here is that your
docker client which is this like docker
run commands and everything you're
working with it's making a call to
docker hub which is a public container
registry and it's looking for this
container image that's tagged Ubuntu and
it always pulls the latest image but if
you want like Ubuntu 3.6 or whatever you
could pull that exactly and what that
looks like on your end is if we just go
of them too so where it's coming where
this is pulling from is all these so
here's all the supported tag so if you
wanted the 18 point one zero in jour
something you can pull that exactly and
this is maintained by the people who
provide the Linux distribution so this
is where you're pulling this container
from and if you've got any of those like
permission issues just make sure you run
that one command to make sure users are
up to speed and so now I've downloaded a
new image for Ubuntu latest and now I'm
gonna see what images I have oh great I
have so many images and the one I have
here was a bun two from two days ago so
that was the latest I already have the
latest so it should show you all the
images that you have available to there
so now that we've downloaded our image
so also all the instructions are in this
like the github so you can follow along
there if I'm going too fast or too slow
or something so now we want to run our
container so we're going to write docker
run Ubuntu and we're going to echo hello
okay so what happened here was your
docker client sent the it looked in your
local workspace for this container
ubuntu and in that it spun it up past
the command that you wanted to run echo
hello through it ran the container
stream the output back to your client
and shut the container down so this is
why docker is fantastic now imagine
setting up a virtual machine however you
do it setting up a virtual machine
waiting four or five minutes for it to
initialize installing all the
dependencies setting everything up and
then running a command and then shutting
it down again so this kind of quick
start quick collapse structure of docker
is what makes it really fantastic for
working and some like some of the dev
stuff where you just want to spin up a
machine run everything through and make
sure everything is working so here's
your output
we ran the open in the open to a
container we ran hello and it came out
so here's a little bit more exposition
the docker client calls the docker
daemon which I'm not completely sure
what that is but I know it's something
that manages the relationship with the
API of how docker setup so it's going to
check locally if the container exists
and because we downloaded the image just
just prior it'll build it creates a
container and runs the command you
specify and then the output of the
command gets streamed to the client and
then the container gets shut down so
maybe you don't want the container shut
down immediately you'd like actually
like to work with it like sick yes yes
this is in if you go back it's the PI
data docker docker start and then you're
an oo docker client ok I should have
labeled those properly say you work on a
Windows machine and you're building
something that was good that was going
to be deployed elsewhere and maybe
they're running Ubuntu and you want to
see what that looks like so what we can
do here is we drop into our bun 2
container right here and you can run
your favorite command essentially in
here whatever that is and you can see
everything that's there and you can play
around with this here and now you've got
this like very lightweight a bunch of
machine just running on your machine -
so that's like one very specific use
case of like what a container just looks
like you can install things in here you
can shut take them out and to exit you
just type exit the one thing that is
great about docker is because all the
instructions are
so five in like so the the the reason
that the Ubuntu images are tagged like
18 point 1 0 18 point 1 4 is that they
will update them over time and all they
have to do to update them is change the
the docker file so just the set of
instructions that builds that image and
we'll go into all of that I'm just
trying to prime that discussion later
huh
and then so we've so far we've pulled an
image we've run a container we've
dropped into a container and messed with
it interactively now we just want to
recap what's going on here so we want to
see what containers you have going oh
that's weird we don't have any
containers going remember every time you
exit a container it shuts down so we
don't have any running containers but if
you want to see what containers you have
run on your machine you can see these
right here so the one we just ran the
command and about a minute and then the
status that it's been exited and then it
just gives it a name because I forgot to
give it a name so I think it called it
gallon pair or something
so here's like background of all the
containers that your machine has run now
remember before we pulled an image so
what does that image store looks like so
let's type docker images and we'll see
here we've still got that image here so
- from a few days ago when I was
workshopping this and we'll see what's
going on there okay so if sometimes the
images can get huge depending on what
you're running like for example if you
have a Postgres image which we'll build
later they can get very big and so
here's some commands that you can use to
clear out the images and the directories
and whatnot so this is like very going
through just what docker looks like
here's an image here's a container what
it means to run what the client is what
a daemon is and so here's a bit of a
review of that before we start talking
about how
work with docker how do we build our own
image how do we build an image that I'm
actually going to use so here's like the
image it's a blueprint for the container
you want to build it's often based on
other images so the image we're going to
construct for example you want to build
an image for Python 3 so that relies on
Python 3 but you install a bunch of
other to other libraries that maybe
aren't in the base so you can pull from
the public Python 3 image that exists on
docker hub so and then make
modifications to it with layers and
these layers you communicate as
instructions in a docker file which is a
very specific syntax and layout remember
container it's built from an image you
pull can you pull images you run
containers and then the docker file has
the instructions for how to build the
image and the specialists in tax it's
well documented by doctor and you can go
there and check it out but sometimes it
gets pretty deep so I kept it very
surface here then the other things of
how docker hub works so everyone kind of
knows how github works right you have
code you version control you push and
pull so docker hub works exactly the
same way but the files you push and pull
are these docker files and so say I have
a version of a prod of a product or a
project and the scope of it changes and
so maybe some of the libraries or
dependencies change and then I have like
this legacy code that maybe necessarily
won't work in the new framework or my
new requirements that I have so I can
have versions of a docker file and ask
somebody to install a specific version
for a project and docker hub is the
public free container registry but Asher
and Amazon Web Services have their own
private container registry so for
example all of our DevOps and everything
happens on our private container
registry and so whenever we have like a
standard set of tools we use when we
work with on when we work on doing like
mortality prediction or geocoding so
we'll pull them in tane can
caner that has all the libraries we need
to work with those packages in one
specific use case we have is when we're
working with a lot of spatial data
we'll need base libraries like Lib geo
and GDL which don't necessarily what
everyone doesn't necessarily have
installed so that's another use case one
very specific use case that I really
like because it kind of shows how you
don't really have to
once you have like docker setup for a
specific use case you don't really have
to worry about it we used to get these
file formats from a client in dot XLS
and that's some outdated version of
Excel that doesn't really work anymore
like you can't open that up on a new
version of Excel and run that file and
so we had no idea what like data set we
were getting and what was going on so
the only tool we found that worked with
it was in the genome Eric library
there's a tool called SS convert but
genome eric is just like huge and i
don't want to put it on my machine and
work with it so we made a docker
container XLS to CSV and all that does
is you pass it a string for the file do
you want to convert and we store it in
blob storage or you could store it in
AWS and s3 and it builds this container
runs it pretty quickly and we maintain
it so you can download the latest
version and that has genome eric
installed and everything it needs and
all it does is it passes the file
through SS convert and then outputs it
as a CSV so that's like a reproducible
data cleaning task that we were seeing
across multiple projects so by having
one docker file or one docker container
that someone could just call and pass
their parameters and their files and
outputs we saw that like that made it a
lot easier to kind of transfer these
tools instead of building a package and
having them install specific things and
running it through that's just like one
use case though I think it's pretty
motivating so I'm gonna go through a
docker file it's not the best example of
a docker file but I think it's an
interesting example of a docker file
I've got like three Postgres is
installed on my computer Postgres is a
open source database and I find it
really difficult sometimes to work with
different for
so I have this docker file that I'll go
back and I open it up and what it lets
me do is work on Postgres machine and
with post GIS installed so I'm
developing code that works against our
database that's deployed in the cloud
but I want to develop locally like make
sure it works and makes sense so what
I'll do is I'll pull from the Postgres
image so let's go back to here and I've
just listed a few of the instructions
that it has so docker file the way
you'll see it setup is it'll be like
from Ubuntu from Postgres from Python
from and then you can give your
container registry name and then exactly
the path you want it to download so this
is kind of the magic of docker is that
people say it specifies the base image
that you will be building everything off
of so if I'm working on I don't know I'm
making a shiny app and I have like
figured out how to deploy a shiny server
so I can test it and make sure
everything works so if I have that shiny
server specified and a docker file I can
tell someone on my team just say hey
just like pull from this docker
container in our container registry one
specific example is sometimes people
aren't team like to experiment the XG
boost and that requires G Fortran and
those kind of files so we have a
container that's specific to running an
extra boost model in production so it
can be a little bit more lightweight in
that sense so we're getting this from
statement and I'll go over this is kind
of how it works so this is like what
people accept as a docker syntax so
you'll have the instructions capitalized
and then the arguments are in lower case
and why not and it looks relatively neat
or how you supposed to do it so these
are the two main commands from and run
that I
consider the workhorses of docker so
from specifies your base image and then
run lets you it just essentially runs
shell commands there's nothing specific
about this that's docker specific it's
just a bunch of shell commands that'll
go and I'll update install post GIS and
setup Postgres PG routing and then so in
the same kind of way yes yes exactly so
your base image and then as you go down
at instructions those are layers and
then the other thing you can add and a
lot of people will have is a label
statement in which which you add
metadata and that can be anything it
could be the name of your container it
could be your email address a lot of
people put it so that they know who to
contact when they have issues with the
container or there's some dependency
that they think is missing to run the
code again the run statement in our case
we're just using it to run the shell
commands another command you'll see
often is this work darer command so it's
not sued it's used it's used to specify
working directory so any other commands
you give following it you won't need to
specify the path and there's also the
add statement which is very helpful
which lets you copy files from your host
machine to the docker container so I've
also included references in the readme
of like the main tutorial file which
takes you to such green pastures as
adding volumes to your docker container
so you can have it so any changes you
make in your local repository will be
synced immediately for example you want
to change the data file that's being
processed through you can just update it
there
it gets a little complicated so I wanted
to keep it simple but if you are
interested in figuring how to link your
container environment with your exactly
your context you can do it through this
and then the other thing is the CMD
statement and it provides a default when
you're get when you're dropping into a
container and you can only have one
valid CMD command per container and if
you provide several only the last will
be used and there's more information at
this link but I just wanted to go
through these so from label
work to your command add Sam D those are
all the commands you're going to see
today and in my opinion I think those
are all the ones you need to get started
so now that we have this like idea about
kind of what docker is I'm going to
pause for a few questions if anybody has
questions up to now so I don't have a
good answer for that because we don't
have best practices on that but when
this how we work on our team is we have
these virtual machines that can be
destroyed any day so what everyone has
been told to do is you keep a docker
file that specifies all your system
level dependencies and configurations
and if that gets down you can pull from
the latest image and so you'll be able
to replicate and all our code well we're
an azure shop and Microsoft is all about
vertical integration so we use like
Azure DevOps which is they bought github
but it's like the face of github or
whatever on our end so that's how that
works for us because data doesn't touch
our virtual machine and like code is
version controlled so you can pull your
repo as it happens but all those system
level stuff will keep a docker file and
an image in our container registry but
that's a good idea if you're like
starting any analyst so reason you're
building a shiny out that you need all
the same things every single time so why
not just run it up yeah that's a good
idea
any other questions I don't know why I
pushed it up I find it it's fine okay
so how many people work with virtual
environments virtual LANs okay do you
ever get the issue where you're stuck
with managing six different virtual
environments and you've got like four
exactly
you've got the issue so like when I was
i I work with virtual M&Ms - I use like
pion to manage everything and it seems
to work fine most of the time but then
I'll say something like oh yeah just
install pip install this requirements
file and everything should work and it
often doesn't and I say just oh make a
new virtual environment pip install and
then everything should work so I'll give
you an example of something happened
last week most of the analytics work we
do happens in like Jupiter notebooks for
exploratory analysis so I push all my
analytics code and I'm like oh here's
the requirements file everything should
work and just I just need you to do peer
review and make sure our work makes
sense because like for regulatory
reasons we like have to go down and make
sure any code we commit has to be peer
reviewed in that sense so my teammate
goes to check is like my version of
pandas is off it doesn't work Baba I was
like hey why don't you use this docker
file build the docker container and
everything will work and it did so that
was a motivating example there the other
thing I often get is my virtual
environments tend to break and I don't
know what I'm doing and I don't want to
probe too far but this seems to work for
me so I put exactly the issues we've
seen if someone builds a tool in a
different flavor of Python with several
package changes and someone is
developing something like a random
forest Explorer or something that you
requires some graphics library that
nobody else has installed and you have
different versions of things so that's
what we find and the use case will set
it will explore here is setting up a
Python like splitting up a Python
container with all the tools required
for a project and then setting up a
Jupiter notebook server with access to
all those resources so you can you can
imagine you have this docker container
and that also has the jupiter notebooks
you need to run things as required so
let's go over the docker file so this is
a little bit of a more expansive docker
file than we saw previously which just
had a
I got from an a run command so let's go
through it and I'll talk about this so
the from command we're pulling from the
Python 3 base image so if you go on the
docker hub you'll be able to see where
this is coming from and then we're just
installing we're just checking for
updates and we're installing pip and
then remember we're caught there's ad
and then there's copy and they kind of
work the same way so here there's a
shortened requirements file for the
project I was working on and what I've
done is copied requirements into the
docker container that's what that does
and then I'm running pip install and
then installing the requirements that
text and then I'm also running pip 3
installed Jupiter and the other thing I
do here is because we don't want Jupiter
to be on route just for security reasons
or whatnot you want to break anything
too badly
so we also add this demo user change to
the user and then specify the work
directory and have given a different
flavor of a CMD command you can also
call entry point and these are just so
for example if you're running a Jupiter
notebook and your terminal you may type
Jupiter notebook whatever this is just
another so what's gonna happen the
Python base image will be pulled it's
gonna run all of these it's gonna copy
the requirements over it's gonna install
all the requirements then install
Jupiter make a new user switch to that
switch to a new working directory and
then run the command Jupiter notebook
inside your container and we'll launch
Jupiter notebook server so if you want
to go ahead oh the other thing about
docker containers is you have to specify
the path to your docker file so
everybody should now be in this dev end
folder on your machine and so it's gonna
build this environment tag it Devon and
then this dot specifies that it's going
to set the context on the context is
just where your docker file is located
all the fun
is that your calling in your dockerfile
are located so yes yeah it's just
switcher but I just want to give a
different example to cuz you'll see it
in many things so we will do this here
Oh see this is the error you get if
you're not in the correct context so
there's no docker file in this directory
which makes sense so I'll switch to
Devon and now I'll do docker build and
I'll tag it Devon and because I already
have it I already built the image it
just runs through in this but it should
like it look like so if you guys want to
go ahead whoever's following along just
build this container
and then we will just I think it takes
some time because some of the packages
take a while to install on your machine
so it's probably just running for you
guys
any questions while we wait and I won't
get to it today yes yes so it would
replace it for that run command if you
go down multiple run commands but work
dear I find is like more helpful for
running just before you're about to
initialize your like final command and
you can only have one of these final
commands right like this commander entry
point so we'll see when we deploy the
app or the the model later on is that
you just use it to call Python main dot
PI and the path that you pass here this
like we're like I want to copy this to
this it has to be respective to the
context and the context is the folder
that your docker file is in so we're in
the same folder so we just past
requirements text yes it's standard that
they're Ubuntu I think listen so there's
also like base Microsoft images that
have never messed around with but if
you're developing an app and you want to
see how it does there it's a Windows
machine so you can test
deployments there too if you don't have
access to all of those and I think a lot
of testing tools that test different
environments use docker on the backend
to you guys know what error flow is like
the pipeline management so they also
know sorry not err phul pachyderm okay
so it's kind of like there's a it's a
pipeline management tool and I've been
playing around with a bit it's a little
complicated but they use docker as their
back-end so you've got like your task
graph and I'll go down and each task is
a docker container and it kind of
exposed all the user functionality of
docker so you for example you could have
a data cleaning docker container that's
triggered every time someone drops data
in your s3 folder or your blob storage
if you're using Azure and then that data
cleaning docker file gets run and it
writes outputs to your database then
when your database changes your it spins
up another docker container which will
run all your modeling tasks and then
write results back to your database and
then it spins up another container that
like output a report and all in
pachyderm manages all of those you can
also manage it yourself
using a tool like docker compose which I
use to serve apps that have maybe like a
database stalker and then also the
front-end docker but pachyderm allows
you to manage like that specific tasks
graph which is pretty cool everybody
kind of it works yes what argument okay
did you pass it like minus T Devon Finn
because you're tagging the image and
then you have there's also a period
there which maybe you missed
yes because what it's missing there I
think is context that work now so once
you get that set up so I'll just show
what the other interface looks like so
we're gonna run and Dockers weird about
ports
you should read up on this I don't fully
understand it but so in the Juke this
jupiter server is running but you have
to map the docker 8 8 8 8 port to our
localhost and then we'll do that
and what else will we do okay we'll pull
Devin's
ok great we're running a jupiter
notebook inside this docker container
and we can access it by just going to
this so just paste this
so here's the Jupiter notebook that's
running inside this docker container and
no matter what flavor or whatever your
machine runs it has all the same Python
packages installed and you can as Python
3 installed and you can open it up and
work with a jupiter notebook here so
does everyone get that you can go back
to so the container is running on your
machine and you've got this notebook
running on that container
remember it's ephemeral right now we're
running it and now we're like ok we
don't care anymore it's gonna shut down
the kernel so not only is the kernel
gone but also the notebook that you
built so if we see again what containers
are running no containers are running
what we see here here is the Devon
container that was created about a
minute ago and this was the command that
we ran in it and it's been exited 10
seconds ago so that's just another
example of you had a Python container
you installed a bunch of requirements
you installed Jupiter on it you served a
jupiter notebook server and then in that
you had access to all them and you can
imagine how if you had some notebook on
your machine you could copy that over
into the docker container and have that
available to you with a specific set of
dependencies in there ok
any questions around that yes yes so you
can mount volumes to your docker
container so that will mean you'll for
example you could have Python script
that you make changes to but it runs in
the docker container it doesn't run
locally so you make changes to it and
the changes persist in the container so
the volume is mounted and if you follow
some of the instructions on docker like
they're at their actual website it's a
lot better explained than I would have
time to do in like an introductory but
that's a really good question because
that makes a big difference in managing
your code and laughs any other quick for
on are they able to get whoever was able
to do it yeah that's the thing would
like the live stuff is I have stress
tested what I was going to show like
seven million times but I'm not sure if
would work for you the whole idea of
docker is that it should work for
everybody but no no sometimes it does
not work okay so I want to leave about
more than about 25 minutes at the end or
half an hour for questions so I'll go
through or if anybody got stuck on
something and also we can talk about
some like really advanced docker use
cases that for me at least or
aspirational but one day so if you want
to switch to this folder called model
deploy I'll just go through this docker
file here so this is a template for how
you can use docker to set up a flask app
and serve
Python model and essentially you can
serve it in such a way that an external
application can then make API calls to
it providing the feature values and get
a prediction and for us at least this is
a standard way that will deploy because
we have a lot of insurance companies who
are our clients and will do things like
build smoker predictor models so based
on seeing this many fields can we
predict whether or not somebody's a
smoker and whether they should be
routered for further testing so on that
end their agent on the insurance company
side has to fill out like a bunch of
questions and they have the other person
on the phone or in person so you need a
real-time response and so they'll enter
a few values I'll make an API call to
our model that's deployed and then in
their UX I'll display directly the
smoker prediction but parsed in a way
that they'll be able to make a decision
based on that whether or not they should
pass this person on for further
screening and that's a very simple way
to deploy model it requires a very
specific specification but it's a really
stable way of deploying a model for
external consumption if you look on any
of like air B&B has that an uber and
they have all these tools like
Michelangelo and they have their own
architecture but this is how you can
build quick models quickly and serve
them without too much infrastructure or
being locked into like a feature
engineering wizard or something in place
so I'll just go through so I'm pulling
this image that has flasks and nests and
runs Python 3.6 specifying the work
directory copying my requirements over
to the app running pip install and then
the other thing I do is one thing I
didn't mention before is setting OS
level variables and here I can do that
using end and first I specify the
variable I want to set and what I want
to set it to and then I copy over my
main PI and
my init pie in a top hat into the app
folder any questions about this
container so this will give us
everything we need to build us and I'll
go over to my main pie and we'll go
through like what that looks like so I
do like all of the imports flask
requests linear model data sets and then
so the data set I'm going to build this
model off of is the diabetes data set
and it's very simple I just train on
everything and use one feature just to
give an example so I take just one
feature and then I create just this
linear model use this one feature and
the target and then I do a pickle dump
and then I specify my app I specify this
like is alive just to check the app is
live and then I specify my prediction
endpoint my API endpoint for the
prediction and then specify what these
arguments look like so it's going to the
argument is F and then it's going to
open the model and then run the
prediction on it and return this
prediction and then remember before we
set the environment to be production
what that's going to do is is going to
specified that you're running on port 80
and the host is local and I just use
that to specify another variable for
flask and in requirements I've got numpy
Sai PI flask pandas scikit-learn nothing
too complicated so let's go here I
didn't put any instructions than that
that's not helpful so we go back and
we'll go to model deploy and remember we
start with the build again so docker
build - t we'll call it model and we'll
do that I've already built the image but
this is what it should look like for you
guys so it's doing at all the steps that
you specified so each layer is being
added I think it takes a bit of time
because scikit-learn take some time to
install
yeah I could do one thing here so I'll
show you what it looks like when you
change your docker file you know I'll
change my requirements maybe I'll add
what should I add I'm a small I'll add
like census geo code so now let's build
let's see what happens when we go to
build the docker so look everything that
was cached has work too like my copying
my requirements over but since I changed
those requirements text file it's going
to run this version thing again so
that's a good way to see how things
change I don't know this is a great idea
since this geo code can take time
but at least this put in kind of on pace
with how people are falling along you're
doing yes so how that TN goal is a
maintained image this image that I have
now this docker file this could be a new
base image I just have to push it to
docker hub so should you remember that
Postgres image we saw I can go back to
it because that's a good example of
making your own base image because say I
want to work with post GIS in something
I'm working on so that lets me work with
shape files a lot better so this is a
good example of a new image that you've
made for yourself that's very basic and
so somebody could now pull this image
whatever you can tag it like post us
upload it somebody could pull that and
then run their queries within that file
within this image and container and
again it's open source so if you want to
make some changes to like the base
Postgres images you can push your own
changes too so we'll go back here okay
so this model build happened and did it
work for everyone is it going shows up
yes your website it's running in another
[Music]
and why it'll give you the tokens might
be the cop you did the first time if
you've never run Jupiter on her
and copy and paste it over it should
work okay
so now that I've got this docker
container build I would love to see what
it looks like when I have a model that's
live so I'll do docker run and I will
pass this port to a tee just so I can
keep track of stuff and I will run my
model container and because in this one
like you spin up like this server
essentially it doesn't shut down
so now we'll navigate to localhost
thousand and we can check here yeah it's
alive so it's up and now we can also
check prediction ah great
we got a prediction so if you're making
API calls you could specify you could
specify your API calls I'm just doing it
in the browser because it's easy but you
just changed just like feature value
that just to clarify everything we'll go
back here because I think maybe I went a
little too fast so at the like when you
specify things in flasks you specified
that you're gonna get this argument F
and that is what I passed here I did I
went to this port that I'd opened open
this like prediction that I'd set up and
then specified the first argument F
equals 0.05 and I can change those 0.07
and change this 0.04 whatever whatever
is within the scope of it and I think
even negative values are within the
scope yes and I'll get a prediction and
I think this is the diabetes dataset and
scikit-learn I forget what the actual
target is it may be some GFR rate if you
can't see that I'm very sorry I will
paste it here
there you go and this is just like a
quick way to see that your app is live
it's running you can pass arguments to
it so what's actually happening on the
back end is you're sending this argument
to this pickled model object and it's
returning the prediction of running that
model of like loading it and the model
dot predict so you can imagine you have
a model with like 20 features you spec
it out you specify all the inputs and
yes okay
you specify all the inputs and if for
example our client on their end is in
putting all these values by hand we have
the spec very carefully and it just
makes the API call passes all those
variables that were input makes the API
call returns the prediction and returns
it to them after that get requests and
most user expects backends will allow
for that oh I just mapped 80 so you just
want it so the command I ran
I'll just exit this this was the last
command I ran so I'm at port thousand on
my local machine
280 I could have mapped 80 to 80 because
this was the port that was specified in
our main dot PI file
the bill that you took with you whiskey
whiskey workers are also with the
workers and yeah both the flats blog and
the whiskey mug will disappear when your
dog comes down yeah so you don't you
have explicitly mouth to get lost
ya know hey how many people hit my
prediction how many people we're smoker
yesterday I make it we're not smoke
yesterday exactly
so to clarify I would not deploy a model
with like a docker container that's up
and down this I used to test mostly what
we will do is we'll use an API
management service within asher and your
docker container will then be the
template for like a virtual machine
that's going to be running and it's
gonna be serving yeah and they'll
persist and your logs will be stored and
will write the logs back to like the
equivalent of s3 yeah yeah and then so
we'll set that process up yeah very much
a dev paradigm just making sure
everything works so if you want to test
something there and you can see how like
once you have this running you can just
copy that over to Azure apps or whatever
the equivalent in AWS is keep missing
them I know like Asia is like a feature
by feature ripoff of AWS but I always
forget which one is which they need to
like publish some mapping yeah so that's
essentially how this whole dr. paradigm
that those are the two most important
use cases I see I have worked on
projects where we used so Luigi has
really good integration with docker and
for each task that we wanted our
pipeline to handle we would write
specific docker containers to manage all
the dependencies and whatnot and then
you can use a docker or container
orchestration layer and
run and deploy all those apps at scale
and one of the best things about that is
if you're running like a thousand models
and you want to paralyze that it's
really easy because you can just set up
a bunch of containers they'll run your
modeling scripts and if you write all
your results and outputs to a database
or something that's more stable then the
containers just disappear after you're
done running it so you don't run out
like large costs on your cloud compute
resources actually fun so you guys know
the 27 to the horse that won the 2017
Preakness Stakes was called cloud
computing one of the members of my team
sent me a fun fact for my presentation
so there's that yes so that's all like
the live demo I have if there's any
questions we could address those or if
you want to walk through kind of like
what your a paradigm is and where you
think docker could fit in or where you
think there are some shortcomings yes
obviously this let you iterate yourself
very well but you talk about like some
of the pain points or stuff that solve
previous
very dynamic so I think it's worth the
trade-off if you're doing something
we're like only your requirements dot
text is changing because they'll like
cash everything up to their right and
those that that versioning works really
well so I would say the our data
engineering team uses docker the most
because they're like developing and
deploying a platform so on there and
they have like a a production
environment and a dev environment so all
their tests are spun up and docker
containers and they make like you know
they want to make sure all the requests
work so they'll send like 10,000
requests and that's a test for something
so they use that and they'll run their
testing environment and docker
containers as required so that's like
much that's like the the maybe the
proper like DevOps use case and this is
kind of like an ad hoc like here's a way
that this works for me and it's kind of
fun to play around with it was very
specific like technical things I think
it could work
but you would need to set in place
measures like so the same way like you
have around code review and things like
that right like you just yeah change
control for environment so if you have a
container registry that is like a repo
for containers and yeah you'll have the
log and everything so it'll have those
versions and you can tag each one so I
can tag like push version one version
two three four and when you run your
basic like docker build it'll pull the
latest version and run that image so it
kind of works the same way as like it
hub would work we also don't have like
good change controls on that around our
theme to try to be the evangelist for
him but I don't know what's going to
happen yeah
I think the docker file is just
executable if you have the docker client
I'm not sure if you have to make it
executable it just looks for something
called if you don't pass a so you notice
that I ran this like dot command if your
docker file just call something not
docker file you pass the name of it
there but if it's just called docker
file capital D lower case everything
else it finds it it runs it
automatically yes any other questions
yeah I don't think the dog follows an
execute I think yeah it doesn't have to
be it's the docker if you pass it to the
client it's just a file manages all that
sorry maybe I got confused
do you think it's worth the pain of
learning how to work with docker to use
it if you test it out let me know how it
goes and if anybody is looking for
employment come and talk to me and we'll
see what we can do that's all I have
[Applause]